Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today, Michael Cohen. Michael is the former
personal attorney to Donald Trump, also author
of the book Disloyal, a memoir and host of
the Mayakoba Podcast. It's really great having
you on. I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Oh, it's good to see you, David.
How you doing, pal?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well. Last time you and
I spoke was on your program and you said two
things that were interesting. I'm wondering
if you if you still feel the same way. One
was, you do believe that ultimately Donald
Trump is going to be indicted and to that,
you do not think that he is going to run for
president in 2024. That was a few months ago.
Do you still feel the same way?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I actually do. Nothing has
changed other than the greater American grift
by Donald and cohorts, whereby, you know,
their whole intent is to make you believe
that they're going to run in 2024, because
the second that they tell you that we're not.
That's when the speaking of funds from all
of these Republican fools that are standing
behind Donald will end up shutting off.
Speaker 1: What is the that? Is that the only
reason to keep the grift going right now that
he may run just to keep fundraising is that
all there is to it?
Speaker 4: Yeah. Otherwise, what else is there
for him? He knows he's not running because
he can't afford to lose the second time. You
see again, the Big Lie is only promoted by
the notion that the election was stolen from
him if in fact, the election was not stolen
from him. What happens to the big lie? You
can't say in twenty twenty four, Oh, they
stole it from me again. It's almost like,
Holy shit, right? Quite frankly, they did
it to us again. They did it again, and it
just doesn't work anymore the first time.
You know, like the old expression, first time.
Shame on you. Second time. Shame on me. Well,
this one would be a shame on me moment. And
Donald can't afford that. And statistically,
he already knows that he can't win the general
election
Speaker 1: on the criminal stuff. Who is going
to charge him and for what crimes, I think
is the most common question I get when the
topic of that comes up. What? What are the
answers to those questions?
Speaker 4: Well, it makes it makes sense,
David, that that's the number one question
that comes through. It happens to be the number
one question that everybody keeps asking me.
Unfortunately, I don't discuss the sum and
substance of the district attorney or the
attorney general's case here in New York.
The things that we do know is that it's predicated
upon valuation of assets using those valuations
for loans and other things. But there's also
then the second half, which is the devaluation
of the identical ad. That's for tax purposes.
Speaker 1: OK, so without getting into detail
about your involvement, it's not the obstruction
stuff that people are talking about during
the presidency. It's these are we're talking
about financial stuff here from the business.
Speaker 4: Well, that's what we're talking
about with the district attorney. The District
Attorney, the state of New York would have
absolutely no jurisdiction over the Jan. six
insurrection. That's clearly federal.
Speaker 1: When you are, I mean, just for
context, for people who may or may not know,
I mean, you had a long history of supporting
Democratic candidates for a very long time,
right? I mean, how do you define your personal
politics?
Speaker 4: David, I've been a Democrat my
entire life in 1987. I worked for Congressman
Joe Moakley of Massachusetts while I was attending
American University. I have been a Democrat
my entire life until ultimately I was required
to switch parties during the campaign because
actions I should say post the campaign because
I was the first Democrat who held the position
as vice chair of the RNC Finance Committee,
and they just couldn't accept that. I mean,
it makes perfect sense. Yeah. And so they
said,
Speaker 1: we can't have a Democrat running
the Finance Committee for the.
Speaker 4: Yeah, well, yeah. Fortunately for
them, it was being run by Steve Wynn, who
just did a remarkable job in terms of fundraising.
It was Steve Wynn myself. It was Elliott Broidy
and Louis DeJoy, right? It was really the
four of us, and obviously they couldn't have
a Democrat on that team.
Speaker 1: So in the last 24 to 48 hours,
we heard about these text messages that were
allegedly sent to the former chief of staff
Mark Meadows on the day of the Jan. six insurrection
that included Laura Ingraham, the Fox News
host texting Meadows and saying, This is looking
really bad.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, I'm sorry. Do we pronounce
it? Is it Ingram or is that Ingraham? I mean,
I've heard people say both personally, I can't
stand it either way. I don't care. I don't
care how you pronounce the last thing. I'm
just trying to. Get an expert meaning yourself.
I'm trying to get an expert analysis on this.
Speaker 1: I've said Ingraham, and people
say that that's not correct.
Speaker 4: I hear it is Ingraham. I hear it
is Ingraham. I like I said, I can't stand
there either way. Does it make a difference
to me? But I just want to at least pronounce
the name right?
Speaker 1: So she was texting Mark Meadows
on the 6th. Sean Hannity was texting Don Jr.
instead of texting. His dad was texting Mark
Meadows. For me, the most interesting thing
about those text messages is that the story
that they told after about it might have been
antifa, and it was really no big deal. They
obviously knew on January six that it was
Trump supporters that were there. What else
do you make of the fact that so many people
from Fox were texting Mark Meadows as this
was going on?
Speaker 4: Are you shocked? Is there anything
about that question that shocks you that Fox
and Newsmax and away in wouldn't be for lying
about this? Seriously? I mean, for God's sakes,
the whole thing again is a it was an insurrection.
And what we know now as a direct result, is
that one hundred and seven eighty seven, one
hundred and eighty seven minutes transpired
before dear old Donald came out and said,
Hey, I want everybody to disperse, go home.
And that's because he had his fun over those
three hours watching these these MAGA fools
running around in paramilitary gear, right?
Beating up on police officers out there with
these massive MAGA flags and Trump 2020. And
you know, God knows what other stupid, swanky
swag that they thought that they were wearing
running around. All right. For the benefit
of who their Führer Donald, and for some
unknown reason, the guy sat there in the in
the White House, in our house, watching this
show on television and thinking that it was
OK, that this is good, that he's going to
somehow stop the electoral decision process
from declaring Joe Biden as the as the president
of the United States, and that somehow he
would be reinserted as president of the United
States for another four years, despite the
fact that he lost by close to, well, nine
million votes and that the electoral count
was it absolute SBT.
Speaker 1: The the stories from that day are
that all sorts of people were urging him to
do this, do this, do that and that he was
ignoring it, at least for a while when you
were working for him. Was that a common occurrence
where you would go and say, this is not good
for you, we need to do a b c and that he would
just ignore it on the idea that he knows more
than you do.
Speaker 4: Right. So Donald knows more than
everybody. Let's just look back because everything
with the reason why I'm so successful in predicting
Donald Trump's stupidity is because, first
and foremost, I graduated valedictorian from
Trump University. All right, that's first
and foremost. Second, it's because nothing
with him is original. It's all like a regurgitation
of tests coming out. So, yes, Donald Trump
does not listen to anyone. Donald Trump knows
more than everyone. Let's look at some of
the things that he said. He knows more about
epidemiology, though he didn't use the word
because he doesn't know the word. Nor can
he spell it right. Knows more about science
than the scientists again, referring at that
point in time to epidemiologist extraordinaire
Dr. Anthony Fauci and the COVID virus. He
knew more about it. What else does old douche
bag Donald know more about? He knows more
about military and strategy than our generals.
I mean, if you're not scratching your head
at this point while watching the show and
say, come on, seriously, the guy already you
know more about seemingly everything than
anybody else. And yet you're an expert in
nothing, right? Why don't we talk about being
since, you know so much how Trump could do,
how Trump Mortgage do right? How did you know
Trump steaks had to Trump suits do. How did
Trump anything do? The brand is worthless.
Because truth be told, he showed himself for
what he really is. And I say it all the time.
He's a racist, sexist, misogynistic, xenophobic,
homophobic, Islamophobic, anti-Semitic germophobe.
That's who he is. And so how you could expect
that this is going to be the guy that knows
more about everybody and everything. It's
just not true. In fact, what do we know? He's
ignorant. He's arrogant,
Speaker 1: hey, on the anti, just to pick
one one of those 10 things on the anti-Semitism
stuff, you know, you were his personal lawyer
for a while, his daughter converted to Judaism,
his son in law, who's Jewish, his grandkids
from from them are Jewish. There are sometimes
these. There are people I've met who harbor
anti-Semitic beliefs, but they sort of want
to be in league with Jews for lightly anti-Semitic
reasons like they think they're clever, like
the Saudis, for example. Now we're very interested
in doing business with certain hedge funds
that are run by Jewish individuals. Can you
talk a little bit about the seeming inconsistency
between the number of Jewish folks in his
family and what you believe to be his anti-Semitism?
Speaker 4: OK. First of all, in order to sort
of care about the Jewish people in order to
care about. Forget about his workers like
myself, Allen Weisselberg, Alan Garten, Larry
Glick and a whole slew of other individuals
that the Trump Organization in high ranking
positions. Right? Being Jewish, he doesn't
care if you're able to accomplish what he
needs. He wouldn't care what race were. Well,
actually, he wouldn't care what religion that
you are. But yes, he does find Jews to be
clever. And so that was something his father
taught him. You know that they're OK if you
work for him. Now, as far as Ivanka, you know,
obviously becoming Jewish and converting,
you know, now being, what do you call it,
you know, Orthodox, but modern Orthodox, having
the three Jewish grandchildren? Why Donald
Trump doesn't care, because in order to care
about somebody else's religion, you have to
care about your own. And Donald Trump does
not care about his own religion because he
had no religious upbringing. Nor does that,
you know, when he turns around and he's holding
the Bible, it's another lie. And he says,
I know more about Corinthian, you know, Corinthian,
too. And so I mean, it's the guy never went
to church. The guy went to church for maybe
his confirmation and then stopped. But he
doesn't have religious convictions. Therefore,
when people say to me, Oh, but his grandkids
Jewish. So clearly he can't be anti-Semitic.
It's the stoop. But his comment that somebody
can make you can't care about, you know, about
Christianity. If you don't care about your
own religion, you can't care about Islam if
you don't care about your own religion. That's
just a fact. He has no religious conviction
at all. Could care less, not just about his
grandkids or his daughter's religion. But
he doesn't care about his daughter or his
grandkids, either.
Speaker 1: Wow. OK.
Speaker 4: That's he a shit about his own
children throughout his entire life. Let's
just let me just back it up with facts. Something
that I continuously do despite the fact some
people want to hear it and those that do already
despise the guy anyway, and those that don't
again would allow him to shoot someone on
Fifth Avenue and get away with it. He walked
out on his three children. That's OK. Many
people get divorced. I get it. He walked out
on them, but he basically had little to nothing
to do with them. He was an absentee father
all along. Don, you know, went to the Hill
Hill School and Ivanka went away to boarding.
School, came back. Then Eric, as soon as that,
he was old enough, went off to boarding school
as well. He, you know, then he has Tiffany
from Marla, sends her off to California, barely
sees her, maybe once a year on her birthday.
They speak all of a sudden. Now it's daddy,
daddy, daddy. Oh, I loved him. He was such
a great father. That's not the way you used
to tell all of her friends, right? And now
you have Barron. When was the last time you
saw Barron? When was the last time like if
if I was president of the United States, I'd
be throwing a baseball with my kid? Right?
That's my son's sport. Right. Well, we'd be
tossing around a football. I would probably
even build a tennis court in the backyard,
so my son and I could hear, well, my daughter
and so on. You see my children. You never
see Barron any way he believes is anything
to do with that child, either. Right? I mean,
now all of a sudden, he's going to worry about
his grandkids. Donald Trump doesn't care about
anyone or anything other than himself. Period.
Drop the mike.
Speaker 1: Michael, last thing I want to talk
about because this has been the source of
such controversy. You were a character in
the infamous Steele dossier and specifically
in the dossier. The allegation was, you went
to Prague, you met with either or both Russian
officials or those who hacked the DNC and
you were involved there. Now you've said it's
it's not even a distortion. It's just not
true. You've never been to Prague, right?
Speaker 4: I've never been to Prague. I've
never been to anywhere in the Czech Republic.
I don't even believe, you know, because my
geography is not great. But, you know, they
claim that I came into Prague through Germany.
I've never been to Germany. In fact, David,
I've never even been to Russia.
Speaker 1: And so do you know why that ended
up in the dossier? Aside from anything else
being true or false, what do you even know
the origin of that yet?
Speaker 4: So the Steele dossier, as it relates
to me and everybody says, well, there were
things in the Steele dossier that are accurate
or potentially accurate there. Therefore,
we can't discount it completely. And I say,
that's fair. That's fair for you to say. But
let me only bring up the 11 allegations raised
about me, right? Anybody else? None of them
are accurate. It's both Christopher Steele
as a joke, as an MI6 agent who supposedly
had contacts and had information and knowledge
that was relevant to this. Christopher Steele
a joke. The MI6 should be embarrassed of this
document. They should be embarrassed that
he ever worked for them. It's just absolutely
untrue. I have said it since day number one.
It has been proven by the FBI that I was never
there. Right? You may even recall that somewhere
along the line, somebody put out, Oh, it was
another Michael Cohen that was there and stone.
But yet they can never produce that Michael
Cohen's passport. I just wasn't there. In
fact, where was I? I was in Los Angeles, California,
with my family, with my son, who was looking
to play baseball as a pitcher for USC Trojans,
and we met with the entire coaching staff.
He was being looked at and say, Oh, you know,
I know for a fact that you can't be in two
places at once and I don't have a twin brother.
So, you know, I don't even know where this
came from. And yet? It was just used and promoted
on and on and on, because this, of course,
would have been a big deal. Now some of the
thing that I testified before the House Oversight
Committee, as well as to the select committees
of intelligence by both the House, the Senate
and other committees and other law enforcement
agencies, was that. I was never in Prague,
however. However, the dissemination of the
Podesta emails I testified that came from
Roger Stone in a phone call. Why that was
never followed through. I don't know the answer.
It's so infuriating when I see now that now
that Democrats have the House right, meaning
the White House put the attorney general,
Merrick Garland, on to it. Roger Stone contacted
Donald. I was there. He put it on the speaker
box and he said nothing shy of in a couple
that I just got off the phone with him. What's
his name from? From WikiLeaks, Julian Assange
to Julian Assange? And in a couple of days,
there's going to be a massive dump of emails
that's going to destroy the Clinton campaign.
And Donald was like, OK, that's great. That's
great. Right? Then after when he hung up on,
Roger said to me, You believe, but I said
this and Roger's right. It's why, of course
you call them the dirty tricks. But listen,
with Roger, you never know. And lo and behold,
was it two or three days later? Massive dump
of Podesta's emails? Did it hurt Hillary's
campaign? It sure did. Did it destroy it?
I don't think it destroyed it. But it was
every single thing that Roger Stone stated.
Speaker 1: Make sure you listen to Michael
Cohen's podcast, the Mayor Culpa Podcast.
The book is disloyal. A memoir. Michael, I
really appreciate your time today. Thank you
so much for doing it.
Speaker 4: David, really good to see you.
Stay, stay safe out there